run these ads will take anything down we
had people bringing in motorized
scooters fake legs bars I've had these
like strippers one time like people hey
hey I need to get a car I need to get a
car oh yeah $3 $4,000 down that's all
you need you can roll with this car oh
was there anything we could work out I'm
like yeah just work out payments give me
the money and I'll I'll get you the car
is there anything you could do that
maybe you like or something that turns
you on and I'm like yeah you know what
turns me on what money pay me and then
that same girl she came in one day and
we had this 2014 Lexus IS 300 and it was
pearl white with like this pink
Christian your interior toal stripper
car and so she came in and I was like
you need 6 grand down to get this car
she's like well I got 1,500 bucks I like
great all you need is a few bucks more
and you can drive it away hour later she
shows up with this older gentleman gives
me 1,500 bucks call her Misty I'm here
for Misty this is her down payment are
you her dad or oh no I'm her boyfriend
hour later another guy comes in same
thing oh hey I'm Misty's boyfriend she
told me that leave like 500 bucks 1,000
he's like I got like 1,800 bucks sure
and literally within a day she had
several men show up and just give me
money and then she drove away the car